where do babies come from where do you
think they come from well I think this
book he he drops it down and then a hole
goes in your body there's blood
everywhere
coming out of your head and then push
your belly button and then your butt
falls off and then you hold your butt
and you have to dig if you find a little
baby
that's exactly right oh don't do that we
love it's almost like Slumdog
Millionaire
[Music]
dan you've got to be a brave boy now I
left my mother when I was your age and
my pups will have to leave me soon but
I'll keep an eye on you if you like
[Music]
I sacrificed a lot for you Sean
I sacrificed Damien for you your tennis
instructor
he was beautiful and Serbian and when
your father left I almost married him
and if I had we'd be living in a condo
clipping coupons and eating lunch meat
are you lost
Stifler's mom uh no no not lost just uh
you know taking the tour
he uh thank you for letting us have this
wonderful party as if there was an
alternative in the matter please she's a
boy I guess we won't be naming him after
my mother he doesn't look much like a
champion what about my cousin Devin
Dillon Truscott pickles dill pickles
yeah
I like it
here you go sprout honey